avec vous Bruno Darroux beaucoup dans
l'émotionnel vous me disiez il a eu des
accusations très fortes contre l'armée
russe et un peu plus tôt il a demandé à
parler directement à Vladimir Poutine ce
qui serait pour lui le seul moyen
d'arrêter la guerre oui bah de toute
façon dans la situation quand même
précaire dans laquelle se trouve volody
mirzelinski même si depuis
8 jours maintenant il fait montre de
beaucoup de de courage et de présence
médiatique ça par contre on assiste
vraiment un match par écran interposé
entre il sait très bien effectivement
que pour lui ce serait beaucoup mieux de
parler directement au président russe
mais évidemment le président russe qui
l'a qualifié de de nazi lui et son
entourage ne peut pas parler directement
avec lui là effectivement la séquence
qu'on a entendu était très effectivement
dans l'émotion parce que en fait en gros
il expliquait que Vladimir Poutine
envoyer chemin de 18 20 ans qui savait
pas trop ce qu'il faisait là en Ukraine
ma fille voilà exactement et que et que
par ailleurs si on a bien compris
l'armée russe avait emmené avec elle des
crématorium pour brûler les corps
des soldats russes tués sur sur le champ
de bataille et donc en fait le
sous-entendu qui est un peu plus
un peu plus calculé je pense c'est que
évidemment les corps de ces soldats ne
seront pas ramenés en Russie à leur mère
ça c'est une thématique à laquelle il a
déjà fait allusion mais le président
Zelinski qui a avant de parler aux
journalistes qui sont entretenu avec le
président Macron
évidemment reste dans une position quand
même difficile compliqué précaire mais
reste un peu droit dans ses bottes même
s'il a pas vraiment répondu à la
question qu'on lui posait sur les
compromis qu'il était prêt à faire pour
que les combats s'arrêtent alors
justement le président Macron vous en
parler qui a parlé aussi à Vladimir
Poutine un petit peu plus tôt et
l'échange à part pas vraiment été
rassurant on va comme on dit en langage
diplomatique ça a été qualifié ainsi par
le Kremlin ça a été une discussion
franche d'une heure et demie quand même
donc ça veut dire que les deux
présidents se sont dit un peu les choses
Emmanuel Macron a répété à Vladimir
Poutine qu'il allait dans le mur qu'il
racontait des mensonges qu'il se faisait
des idées en pensant que le régime
ukrainien était régime politique qu'il
allait payer très cher faut que ça
allait que cette guerre cette invasion
de crâne allait lui coûter extrêmement
cher et qu'il finirait affaibli et isolé
et de son côté Vladimir Poutine a fait
comprendre à Emmanuel Macron qu'il avait
regardé son discours hier soir et qu'il
n'avait pas vraiment apprécié certaines
accusations en particulier quand
Emmanuel Macron qualifié de mensonges
encore une fois le fait de vouloir des
nazifier un pays qui par essence pour
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas nazi en tout
cas ça conforte quand même le le statut
de super médiateur un peu maintenant de
d'Emmanuel Macron qui parle depuis le
début de l'invasion pour la troisième
fois au téléphone avec Vladimir Poutine
et qui est également en contact régulier
avec le président Zelinski
[Musique]
beaucoup Bruno pour pour votre analyse
dans ce contexte de